I've got the eye of the times
[Applause]
[Music]
King Charles celebrates its coronation
with a star-studded concert Katy Perry
giving Regal Renditions of Roar and
fireworks
[Music]
you're gonna hear me
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm grateful I get to go and I'm at King
Charles a few years ago and he named me
as an ambassador to one of his
organizations the British Asian trust
which it really aligned with my values
but it's so cool Katie's fellow American
Idol judge Lionel Richie also hits the
stage
[Music]
getting King Charles dancing on his feet
foreign
it's an honor I mean I mean first of all
you know you you've been in the business
a long time and of course when you get
an invitation like this the answer is
absolutely uh we've been friends a long
time I've known it I've known him a long
time but to be asked is is the whole
thing also part of the occasion pianists
long Long's performance of Reflection
from Disney's Mulan
and a collaboration with Nicole
Scherzinger
[Music]
[Applause]
nickel heard the Reflection from Mulan
she said she's going to sing that so it
was a it's a really great chemistry this
song brings love and to to people and to
bring
self-confident
and
I always love this melody of course
Charles's son Prince William couldn't
miss the event he takes a stage two
honoring his dad with a few words for
over 50 years in every corner of the UK
across the Commonwealth and around the
world he has dedicated himself to serve
others
Paul
we are all so proud of you yeah and the
Celeb moments keep going with virtual
appearances from Hugh Jackman Tom Cruise
and Pierce Brosnan Tom even has a
special message for King Charles
[Music]
plus Kermit the Frog and Miss Piggy
providing his majesty with some
entertainment we're actually uh we're
looking for our seats you know we are
we're in the Royal box
foreign